thank you Maggie
thank you Maggie and thank you
conference is so fantastic to see you
all here this morning in good spirits
um and it's such a pleasure to be here
with my London labor family really good
to see you all in a city which knows
better than some parts of our country
the difference that labor in power could
make
from Hackney to Hounslow lewisham to
Brent we're standing by our communities
in this cost of living crisis making a
difference you see it right across the
city
cheaper bills on Waltham forest and
Enfield award-winning home insulation
scheme the safest streets in Redbridge
Community enforcement hubs tackling
anti-social Behavior the primary school
children no longer going hungry in
Westminster labor Westminster
[Applause]
and in City Hall under sadiq's
leadership we're showing how to build a
New Britain
now a few weeks ago you probably saw
just down the road in Hackney I spoke
about sticking plaster politics
about how without reform Westminster is
incapable of delivering the change that
our country needs how we need a new
politics which trusts communities to
control their own destiny
conference we know what that looks like
here in London we've seen it here for
eight years and we're going to make it
12 next year
[Applause]
it's more new homes that at any time
since the 1930s more new Council homes
than any time since the 1970s a golden
era of house building which is tackling
London's affordability crisis at source
long-term Solutions
Dynamic local leadership communities in
control that's the antidote to sticking
plaster politics
that's the difference that labor makes
in power
but conference
that difference
it starts with the party
it starts with you
without your hard work your enthusiasm
your hope for a better future
the door knocking the casework the quiet
conversations with your community rain
or shine
nothing we hope to achieve for our
country is possible so I want to say
thank you to all of you for all of that
but my thanks are not just for our
victories together
it's also about our values who we are as
a party
three years ago
when I became leader
I knew we had a huge task ahead
we had to change our party and prepare
for power all in one go
not change for change sake
change with a purpose to make our labor
party fit to serve our country
that's why we had to support NATO and
show its non-negotiable
show we want business to thrive and
prosper
understand the importance of ceremony
country first party second
but most of all
it's why we had to rip anti-Semitism out
by its roots
this has been on my mind this week of
course it has
only yesterday like many people here I'm
sure
I paused to remember the worst evil in
human history
to reflect on the burden of anxiety and
pain Jewish communities still carry as
part of that history
and to say as we do on Holocaust
Memorial Day every year
never
again
last week Johnny Newton from the
community security Trust
put out a message about our journey on
anti-semitism
but before I share it with you
I need to be clear about exactly what
the community security trust does
they campaign against anti-Semitism of
course
but their main focus is protecting Jews
from hate from intimidation from violent
attack in their communities that's
synagogues at schools conference this is
the awful reality Jewish communities
still face in Britain the work of the
community security trust is vital
but Johnny's message is clear and
painful to hear
he says
in 2018 and 2019
labor-related anti-semitism
was a key driver of sustained
anti-jewish hatred
that's the stain we are trying so hard
to remove from our party
but he goes on
because now in 2023 he praises the work
we've done meticulously developing and
implementing new policies warning
against complacency no equivocation
conference let me be clear this work
never stops our commitment to fighting
all forms of hate and discrimination
never stops never again never stops
[Applause]
[Music]
it's up to us everyone here in this room
to keep up the work of fighting
anti-Semitism and changing our party
because if we stop for one moment then
we forego the right to change our
communities our cities and our country
that's what a party fit to serve the
country means it's why
it's why our victory in Barnet last year
was the proudest moment of my leadership
[Applause]
so I say to Jewish communities There and
Everywhere we know we must never let up
and we won't
but that moment in Barnet
I felt for the first time in a while
that labor could return the gays of the
British people with confidence
conference that's the foundation we've
laid together
and now we've got to build on it I want
to walk into Parliament after the next
general election and see Dan Tomlinson
representing shipping Barney
Joe Powell representing Kensington
Rachel for the two cities David for
Hendon and Danny
there's going to be some Jubilation
across the country when we see you there
let's kick Johnson out
[Applause]
[Music]
conference make no mistake we'll have to
work for it the Taurus will never give
up on power that's not who they are
so no let up no complacency fight for
every vote
Britain is crying out for change crying
out for decisive leadership and we must
provide it
prove that we can be a bold reforming
government show not just what the Tories
have done to Britain but the Britain
that labor can build a fair agreed a
more Dynamic country with an economy
that works for everyone not just those
at the top and the politics which trust
communities with the power to control
their own destiny
now this is crucial
economic change must go hand in hand
with political change
we have an economy that holds potential
and a politics that Hoards power
no similar country puts so much decision
making in the hands of so few people
and it's no coincidence this leaves us
with more Regional inequality than
anywhere else in Europe
no accident it leads to the moral
bankruptcy we see played out every week
from the Tories in Westminster
I'm not going to waste too many words on
the Tories here
damage they've done to our country
to our finances and public services to
our reputation all around the world
it's immense
sticking plaster politics will never end
with them
they're not capable of the change that
Britain needs
and as for the cynicism of what they'll
do at the next general election
to try and claim some kind of political
credit for the sacrifices working people
are making now
as if the ambulance waiting times the
burger is going unpunished the mortgages
through the roof are somehow not their
fault
no
this is why we've got to rise to the
moment
give people a sense of possibility again
light at the end of the tunnel
and look let's be honest
this is going to be hard
every policy we announce must be fully
costed
the lesson of the last year is Stark
lose control of the economy and its
businesses are working people who pick
up the bill
we can't let that happen
even when it puts a break on things good
labor things we might like to do in
power
we have to understand sound money in our
public finances comes first
but at the same time
we must be bold on reform on
reconstruction or national renewal
that's what the British people expect
from a labor government and we will
deliver
because for all the challenges we face
I remain optimistic about our future
I believe in our country I believe in
our businesses I believe in our people
and I believe in our spirit
so let's get on the doorstep and show
people how we can change our country
let's show them our plan for Grassroots
growth
how we go to end the Tory era of low pay
with our new deal for working people
reform business rates to give our high
streets a Level Playing Field spread
Economic Opportunity and control out of
Westminster to every community
tell them about our partnership with
business
a modern industrial strategy that will
drive Innovation raise investment
harness the power of new technology and
put it to work for working people
let's explain that we would stop the
energy price cap creeping up again in
April
that would stop prepayment meters being
imposed on people
and that the labor party would never sit
on its hands when a fairer share from
oil and gas companies could help working
people in crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
but also be clear that sticking class to
politics
is not enough to end the cost of living
crisis
though we have to have a plan for the
long-term cure that we will insulate 19
million homes that we will invest in the
clean British energy that gets us
cheaper bills forever
that will give our country energy
independence from Putin forever
and with Great British energy
that we will turn the golden opportunity
of clean energy into the secure
well-paid jobs of the future for every
community
conference
be clear about this as well
only labor understands that you can't
fix our economy
without first fixing our Public Services
that's why we'll reform the employment
service to get more people back to work
give everyone who needs it access to
mental health treatment within four
weeks
build a modern child care system that
supports parents and women to flourish
more police on the streets more
affordable housing more support for our
NHS
you know
one of the great privileges of being
born in Britain
certainly for all my life
is knowing that if you get ill
if you have a serious accident
you'll get decent Health Care
whatever your circumstances
not every country has that and the
anxiety it causes is huge
but when you've got seven million on
waiting lists and Rising when you've got
to fight tooth and nail to get a GP
appointment in three weeks time
when you call an ambulance for a stroke
and it won't get there for an hour and a
half
isn't that precisely where we are
conference we can't let sticking plaster
politics destroy our NHS I won't stand
for that and labor won't stand for that
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why we've got a fully costed plan
for the biggest NHS training program in
its history
we'll tackle the capacity crisis with
more doctors more nurses more Health
visitors
will broker a fair pay agreement that
will transform the pay and conditions
for every carer in the country
and we'll reform the NHS so once again
people can get the care and security
that they deserve
conference every day until the election
this is our job
we need to take our positive message to
the hearts and ears of the British
public
work each day to win their trust match
their ambition for our country
and enjoy the task
because amongst all the chaos
there is a growing impatience for change
for National renewal
and as they have in the past the British
people are turning to labor to provide
it that's the value of a changed labor
party
but I say again
no complacency
our message at the next election must be
that we're different to the party that
Britain rejected in 2019.
with the point of the changes we've made
we must say we must say never again will
labor be a party of protest not public
service
[Applause]
never again will labor felt across the
economic stability is the foundation of
our ambitions never again will labor
allow hate to spread unchallenged
we've changed our party and we're ready
to change Britain
[Applause]
ready to build a fairer Greener more
Dynamic Britain where working people
succeed aspiration is rewarded Public
Services work communities control their
own destiny of Britain with a sense of
hope and possibility once again that's
what this labor party stands for let's
make it happen thank you conference
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]